[Musique]
si ma mère avait eu cette possibilité
je crois qu'elle aurait signé ce
document
si j'ai cette possibilité dans les
prochaines années de signer ce document
je le ferai c'est important de bien
faire un travail consciencieusement
savoir que les termes sont compris mon
progressait avec respect là-dedans c'est
important
c'est un sujet sensible après avoir
manqué tant l'année dernière avant les
élections pour élargir l'aide médicale à
mourir le gouvernement de François
Legault dépose un nouveau projet de loi
qui doit entre autres permettre les
demandes d'anticipées c'est la ministre
déléguée à la santé et Sonia Bélanger
qui porte ce dossier délicat nous la
joignons à Québec madame Bélanger
vous avez dit que la société québécoise
est prête à un élargissement de l'aide
médicale à mourir qu'est-ce qui vous
fait dire ça
mais en fait il faut revoir vraiment le
contexte au Québec par rapport à l'aide
de médicaments par rapport aux soins de
fin de vie en général depuis 2010 il y a
eu plusieurs travaux plusieurs
discussions publiques plusieurs débats
et entre autres la grande thématique de
mourir dans la dignité puis en 2015 on a
eu notre premier projet de loi donc sur
les soins de fin de vie alors
aujourd'hui 7 ans plus tard on regarde
toutes le chemin parcouru puis on doit
revoir rediscuter des conditions dans
lesquelles les personnes actuellement
demandent l'aide médicale à mourir puis
on doit élargir selon ce que les gens
nous ont exprimé vous avez dit que vous
voulez pas banaliser l'aide médicale à
mourir mais quand on regarde la
proportion de décès qui découle de la
médicale à mourir c'est une proportion
qui augmente quand même assez rapidement
on est rendu à 7% devant les pays devant
la Belgique est-ce que pas un risque si
cette proportion-là continue d'augmenter
que des gens se sentent d'une certaine
façon poussée à avoir recours à l'aide
médicale à mourir comme si justement ça
devient un geste banal comme si une
pression sociale pour qu'on est recours
à l'aide médicale à mourir en fin de vie
ben écoutez c'est un sujet qui est
tellement critique qui est tellement
important on parle ici de la vie des
personnes d'une étape cruciale qui est
la fin de la vie et c'est pour ça que
dans la loi sur les soins de fin de vie
il faut se donner je dirais des
modalités des processus des bons guides
c'est extrêmement important et pour
éviter toute forme de dérapage possible
donc quand on parle d'ouvrir la loi
c'est de renforcer certains critères
l'autre chose très rapidement nous avons
une commission sur les soins de fin de
vie au Québec qui jouent un rôle
extrêmement important de gardien cette
commission de soins infirmerie produire
un rapport annuel qui est déposé à
l'Assemblée nationale et ça c'est très
important et on a donc des bons
mécanismes pour suivre tout ça de près
parlons justement de ce que vous voulez
inclure dans votre projet de loi par
exemple les demandes anticipées une
personne pourrait avoir recours à l'aide
médicale à mourir si elle en fait la
demande une fois qu'elle est atteinte de
démence atteinte de maladies d'Alzheimer
comment s'assurer que la volonté de
cette personne là soit respectée une
fois qu'elle n'est plus apte finalement
à demander ses soins là premièrement la
demande anticipée la demande anticipée
c'est aujourd'hui j'ai un diagnostic je
suis en mesure de
de comprendre qu'avec le diagnostic que
j'ai prenons l'exemple du diagnostic
d'Alzheimer je sais que je m'en vais
vers une perte d'autonomie et je ne veux
pas me rendre là je le sais aujourd'hui
alors je vais faire une je vais
soumettre mon intention de faire une
demande médicale
anticipé et il y a tout un processus qui
est prévu pour dans le fond premièrement
y aller avec des tiers de confiance des
personnes en qui j'ai confiance qui vont
avoir discuté avec moi puis après ça
avec un médecin ou une IPES avec une
équipe professionnelle et en fait c'est
de décider de la fin de ma vie c'est
vraiment ça la demande médicale
anticipée ça c'est le premier élément le
deuxième élément nous avons intégré
notre projet de loi les personnes ayant
un handicap neuromoteur j'aimerais vous
parler du handicap neuromoteur oui
savoir à quel point par exemple
quelqu'un qui fait un accident
ça peut être une personne quand même
assez jeune une personne de 20 ans qui
aurait encore toute la vie devant elle
des années de vie devant elle si ce
n'était de l'aide médicale à mourir à
quel point c'est un changement de
paradigme à votre avis ce qu'on
introduit là au Québec mais écoutez je
pense que les personnes qui présentent
des handicaps neuromataires ont souvent
des troubles graves du système nerveux
avec vraiment une situation dans le fond
où ils deviennent en quelque sorte
prisonniers de leur corps avec des
souffrances et puis tant que la personne
vit bien avec ça qu'elle est dans son
plein potentiel de réadaptation bien
c'est correct mais vous savez nous avons
des situations on en a vu au Québec là
des personnes qui n'étaient pas
éligibles à la médicale à mourir parce
qu'il n'était pas en soins de fin de vie
mais elles étaient dans des situations
d'anticap neurotteurs avec des
souffrances physiques psychologiques qui
étaient souvent très difficile à
soulager avec une irréversabilité de la
maladie ça c'est vraiment important
aussi le volet de l'irré versabilité et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut avoir la
discussion sur en particulier la notion
d'handicap ne remontage en autant
naturellement que ça réponde à tous les
critères qui sont la loi sur les soins
de famille donc dans le projet de loi
madame Bélanger les infirmières
praticiennes vont pouvoir pratiquer les
médicaments ça devrait être accessible
dans les maisons de soins palliatifs
mais j'aimerais aussi aborder ce qu'il
n'y a pas dans le projet de loi
notamment il n'y a pas la question de la
maladie mentale et pourtant
Ottawa ça doit être un critère dès
l'année prochaine pourquoi ne pas avoir
voulu faire ce débat là
[Musique]
qu'ils ont reporté la mise en
application pour le trouble mental
et ça c'était supposé être en
application en mars cette année mars
2023 ils ont reporté en 2024 mais c'est
pas une garantie
qu'en 2024 ils auront terminé leur
discussion peut-être une question un peu
plus personnelle en terminant madame
Bélanger on vous a senti émotive à un
moment donné pendant le point de prêt
jeudi dernier je vous sentais presque
que vous aviez les larmes aux yeux
qu'est-ce qui vous rend émotive par
rapport à ce dossier là
écoutez je pense que pour moi c'est un
c'est un honneur de pouvoir porter un
projet de loi qui est extrêmement
important et puis naturellement quand on
parle de soins de fin de vie on a tous
dans notre entourage des gens qu'on aime
qui
sont dans des situations actuellement
avec peut-être certains ont des maladies
incurables ou d'autres situations puis
naturellement je pense que quand j'ai eu
des émotions c'est que ça faisait
référence à ce que les proches autour de
moi vivent si on avait lancé je vous
remercie beaucoup merci beaucoup au
revoir au revoir